are you ready for the MCU to get a lot
bigger the Marvel's hits theaters on
November 10th and there's a lot to be
excited for we've got all the details on
the Marvels now the Marvel universe is
no stranger to crossovers even so the
Marvel's is sure to be a particularly
exciting crossover moment what the this
film will see Carol Danvers AKA Captain
Marvel Monica Rambo and Kamala KH aka
Miss Marvel join forces fans of all
these characters know just what it means
to have these superheroes getting
together you need all kinds of skill
sets all kinds of people with different
viewpoints and different backgrounds in
order to save the world yep these ladies
have all the bases covered when it comes
to superpowers and Cala who's Camala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of